i am for securing this state i
am pro law enforcement i'm pro
border protection okay ice pro ice
we need these people and they do a
wonderful job give us your assessment
boots on the ground in california
what is the caitlyn jenner constituency
does she stand a chance
of unseating gavin newsom
john i truly think that anything is
possible at this point the fact that
the fact that over two million people
signed the recall in the first place now
this one-party very corrupt state they
they eliminated like 400 000 of the
signatures because suddenly they care
about
signature verification but but the
recall is happening
everyone hates newsome i i mean i can't
i can't
overstate this i meet all sorts of
people
every day in la when i when i do leave
my house which i do every now and again
and these are democrats that want this
guy out these are apolitical people that
want this guy out as far as caitlyn
specifically
you know if this thing is real and it's
not just a publicity stunt and i hope
that is right and
and i'll be uh i'll be totally
transparent john i did donate fifty
dollars and i got the caitlyn for
california mug i should have had it with
me on set right now
but the policies that she has laid out
there and i watched the entire interview
with hannity
there was nothing that didn't make sense
right there really wasn't
you know she's even fighting the trans
lobby on this stuff that girls
you know that that biological boys that
transition to girls shouldn't be in
girls sports
the obvious feminist position and
sensible position but that's just the
sidebar issue
but the things that are important to
californians like lowering taxes and
getting
rid of regulation and opening up the
state and and helping with the homeless
situation and dealing with the the drug
situation that is completely out of
control i mean go to downtown l.a it is
an
absolute disaster or basically go to
anywhere
uh in san francisco and it's absolutely
awful
so she's getting the issues right and
and i hope that this thing is real
and it's like you know i would put the
rest of it aside is it a little odd
that if you would have said to me 20
years ago the best candidate
for governor in california would be
bruce jenner as a woman yeah it's a
little odd but yeah
we're doing this a lot i was saying the
other day you know they're trying to
make like actual
sod like illegal in las vegas and i was
saying like 20 years ago you
told me that grass like marijuana was
legal but sod was illegal i would have
called you a lie but here we are
anyway i wanted to play dave's great
follow on social media i know a lot of
people do follow him but in case you're
not
you get stuff like this play the clip
guys
uh okay you're checked in yeah thank you
here's your aids raven uh no
you don't want to wear an aids ribbon uh
no no but you have to wear an aids
ribbon
i have to yes yeah see that's why i
don't want to
but everyone wears the ribbon you must
wear the ribbon
what you are you're a ribbon bully
and they of course in the subtitles
replaced ribbon with vaccine here that
it
is a great episode i can't imagine that
episode even probably making it
to prime time television day too edgy
for today's audience
but you know i love kramer i don't i
don't want it because i have to
well first off every episode of seinfeld
would would not be allowed to be on
television at this point the soup nazi
come on i mean
the whole show would be taken off there
let's not forget jerry once
drugged a girlfriend so he could play
with her toys
and i could i could continue but it was
trip to fans it was tryptophan come on
it was it was that no he got it was a
little bit of wine and the tryptophan
from the turkey you're right you're
right
um but you know i try to put things like
that up there to make a broader point
because you know we can all do the
political thing all day long and we can
drug people over the head with this
stuff
but the beauty of that scene is that
kramer's saying hey
i'm here i support the fight against
aids
like i'm gonna walk i'm gonna raise
money all that stuff but it's never
enough
for the activist class and that is what
we are seeing
with blm that's what we're seeing with
the workstars they want
your complete submission and let's not
forget what happens
to kramer at the end of that i mean
basically the activists the so-called
good guys
they end up beating the crap out of him
does that sound kind of familiar
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell